a second ethics advisor walks out on
boris johnson after what he himself
labelled an exceptionally busy year did
the prime minister pregnancy i think
prime minister's views are clear in the
letter that he sent to me on the on the
31st but do do have a look at that okay
thank you very much in a one-sentence
resignation statement lord guyt gave no
reason for quitting in an appearance
before mps on tuesday there were a few
hints
on accusations that he was too close to
number 10
how can i defeat the impression that
you're
suggesting of a sort of uh
of a sort of cozy insufficiently
independent uh relationship i think it's
very hard and on whether he'd ever
considered resigning
this response there are a few
instruments available to an independent
advisor and um
important to
consider what is going to work best
again i haven't
i haven't given you a direct answer in
14 months in the job clashes resulted in
multiple threats to resign it seems
tuesday's committee appearance was the
final straw
the ethics advisor who resigned tonight
had been the principal private secretary
to the queen
the challenge for boris johnson now is
whether he can find another ethics
adviser of anything like the same
standing and what impact will this whole
row have on tory mp's confidence in them
critics quick to point to the bigger
pattern
i think he wanted to achieve change he
wanted to improve the ethical standards
in downey street and he thought he'd be
able to do that
um but he was repeatedly lied to by the
prime minister personally and by the
prime minister's team
lots of good people go to work at downey
street and then
they get consumed in the bonfire of
boris johnson's narcissism and
and their reputations are the ones that
are tarnished and ruined
number 10 insist lord gait's resignation
is a total surprise having indicated
earlier this week he was happy to
continue in the job for months to come
now his departure yet another headache
for a prime minister trying to perform a
relaunch sam coates sky news westminster